[Music]
hello everybody
i'm pleased to be talking today with my
friend and brother charles joseph
charles is a member of the quakawa
people who have lived for thousands of
years on what is now the west coast of
the canadian province of british
columbia
he's an accomplished artist who works
primarily in cedar carving and has
produced a body of work within and
extending his native tradition including
a 50-foot totem pole which was installed
in 2017
on sherbrooke street in montreal in
front of the montreal museum of fine art
and which stands there to this day
i met charles about 15 years ago when i
intended attended a little craft fair in
comox on vancouver island in british
columbia i thought it would be all
hippies and candles and mostly it was
but my wife tammy convinced me to go so
i did
charles had set up an exhibit there in a
tent on the advice of his wife as it
turned out and he'd placed a couple of
his carvings outside i walked by and
thought
whoever did that is a real artist not
just a hippie and went in
i told him how much i liked his work i
always liked that style of work that
native western style of carving ever
since i was a kid and he showed me a
photo album which contained an almost
unbelievably large
range of carving style and motif
that day i bought a couple of small
pieces but we made an agreement that he
would send me a carving every six months
around there and i would buy it and we
just continue doing that for as long as
we were both happy with the arrangement
and that lasted for about 10 years
before we started on a more major
project together
i'll tell you the rest of that story as
we continue our discussion
as i got to know charles over a few
years
eventually inviting him out to toronto
he revealed more of his history and
we're going to talk about that today
along with discussing his arts and
traditions and sources of inspiration
i need to tell all you people watching
and listening that this is not going to
be an easy conversation and i'm not
saying that lightly
we're going to start by thanking the
crew chris wycott that helped charles
set up this interview from inside his
carving tent sugar cane just outside of
williams lake in central british
columbia the property owner there is
daryl sellers
hey charles
hey jared
good to see you man
it's been a long time yes really good to
see you yeah
yeah it has been a couple years
yeah so i
so why don't you tell tell what you
remember about his first meeting
okay uh it was in comox
and uh art show was called nautical days
and i got invited to go by my
i was reluctant to go at first because i
wasn't sure what was gonna happen there
i've never been to it but i decided i
care to set up a table
and at that time the first couple days
there is
barely anybody reaching my table so i
brought my bastard house
and my fastest home bastard homes were
there that day and you and your wife
showed up
i said could i pet your dogs
and then then you guys walked in and
started looking at all the button
blankets that were hanging behind me and
all the art that was on the table
and from from that day on we became
close friends and
i love it yeah well you told me
something striking that day or late not
not like not long after that i think i
think you told me that i was the first
white guy that you'd really made a
friendship with
is that right yeah yeah
the reason for that jordan i was
reluctant to have uh non-native friends
because of my residential past
um
i wasn't sure if i could trust
anybody that way
yeah well you you told me the story and
that's one of the things i want you to
do today and that unfolded for us over a
couple years as we got to know each
other and it was pretty damn harrowing
to listen to to say the least
and so i thought one of the things we
could do today is well i'd like you to
tell your story right from the beginning
you told me about your grandparents and
about when you were young when you were
in the hospital
people should know this
well it started off as i grew up with my
great grandparents and my mother and
father gave me to my great grandparents
on my father's side
my great-great-grandparents
were there and
my great-grandparents were the ones that
grew me up looked after me and then when
i got
put into a residence school
they they
they were there trying to retrieve me
back because they took me from the
hospital right like the residential
school people grabbed me from the
hospital without three other kids that
time
i was five years old just turning just
about probably five five and a half
years old when they grabbed me yeah well
you told me you'd spent quite a bit of
time in the hospital because you got
sick with a number of things
simultaneously and at that time you also
didn't speak english
no no english at all and i got
chickenpox measles and lumps right all
and all and one after another so i stuck
in the incubator for quite a while first
they they
they took me out of alert bay and i
can't remember where it was you know
what hospital was but
i was in this plastic
oh
i guess there's an inch baiter
plastic singer there's no blankets on
you or nothing because your blankets
would get stuck to me
or anything like that when i was had
chickenpox measles
but uh when i was this young boy and
there's nobody in the room with me
no one will seem to be allowed to come
around me
but this young boy
i always remember this story because
he's the first one that gave me a toy to
play with in this incubator thing
because i had nothing to play with right
so
he stacked up these books they were
reached the crib that i was in that's
how small we were five years old
so i was in this party stack these books
up in zero
toy and he couldn't completely reach
over so he threw it in and then
climbed back down off those books and
i had i had to tie my hand and
i guess i excited just for that toy and
him for doing it right and
i got to play with that toy until i got
to leave that hospital and then when
they end up back in alert bay hospital
and all of a sudden i got picked up by
this residential school
well you i think you told me
i think you told me that you were on the
dock waiting for your grandparents your
great grandparents to pick you up
no no no i was in the hospital in the
waiting room and they were down the dock
waiting for a taxi but they got there
too late right i was already picked up
by these people
and i never knew them
i couldn't speak english to ask where
what was going on where was i going
so by the time
that happened i was in this residential
school and it was a big red brick
building
now as soon as i got inside those doors
my life changed within seconds
because i got thrown to the floor and i
cut my hair
uh took all my clothes off and put these
funny-looking clothes on me and
shoes
four times too big for me
and uh
just a minute
yep
and uh
still gets tough
yep
and i was um sitting on my bed they put
me towards him i wasn't sure what was
going on then
because i had these
funny-looking clothes on and i had a
haircut and they were treating me
uh three o'clock came around there's
kids everywhere
hanging on to my bed
very tight wonder what what kind of
hospital is this
why is this
why are they allowed to run around and
i'm not
and these three boys are standing there
there's a new kid this new kid
that was me
and from that day on those three boys
became my friends my brother brother
we grew up together in there for quite a
few years
instead of trying to look after each
other's back i guess you might say
and they were teaching me the ropes of
residential school what what not to do
and what to do
i still never caught on because i
couldn't speak english properly so i
wasn't really couldn't really understand
what they were teaching me
so i got whipped and strapped and thrown
in the closet quite a bit because of
that not knowing
and it's got it got worse from there
just like i
got hurt by a nun and then preacher the
following day so you were confusing then
throughout the years about whether i
should be with a woman or a man because
of what they did to you
and i never
i never
got to learn how to read or write
properly or
you told me charles that you had a hard
time finding enough to eat when you were
in the residential school
um
i'm only laughing because it hurts um
they uh
you could smell all the good food like
corn cob roasts stuff like that and
you've never seen it you didn't it
wasn't on your plate
but you could smell it and made your
stomach growl really loud because you
never got to eat like that
sometimes your porridge would be moving
in your
in the same cords
for days until it's all gone and they
wouldn't change it or renew your big pot
of porridge until you ate it all
and and
sometimes your bread
should have been thrown away but they
gave us for sandwich baking and all he
had was peanut butter
and
to this day i have a hard time with
pickles and peanut butter because that's
all you got for your sandwich and your
lunch
there's no apple or oranges or juice you
know it was just
that in water and the water came out of
the tap from the school
you said you used to forage with some of
the kids for eggs
and so forth and try to cook them under
the hot water taps
we used to crawl around on the beach
then like sneak out at night and go down
and get mussels off the beach i don't
know why i knew that
but we'd get these little muscles and
then we'd
put them in our t-shirt and fold our
t-shirt up like a bag so we could carry
it in and sneak back you know that
and then on the spring
we go into the forest always sneak into
the forest
and and
we'll take robin's eggs
and and bring them back to the dormitory
and
boil it under our taps under hot water
and
little did we know that the mussels
smell you could smell it so the diamonds
that we got caught doing that right and
they wanted to know where's the shells
where's that food
we all the whole dormitory took a
licking that time we got a
strapping and a whipping because no one
would own up because they knew we were
feeding someone hungry that day so we
all took a beating for it
you talked about the closet
wonder we're done with
well
when you're done with some um
i'm asking you
you're sitting in a closet for five
five days
start closet
where you can't stand or sit down
properly or lay down you just sit there
with your legs
bend up to your chest
it's really dark in there
and when they
when you you're probably out of the
closet it's so bright out that you're
black opera
then you wake up on the floor getting
kicked around
get up do your chores
oh yeah get put back in there again
and you're waking up
from being kicked around and then you
don't even know what your chores are
because you're blacked out when you're
they're telling you what they want you
to do
so you get into more trouble because you
don't know where your chores are what
you're supposed to be doing
how long were you in this school
i was in there for nine years
probably
three four years of it you weren't
allowed to go home
what did you think about your family not
being there
um
i thought
i never really thought more of them i
thought what did i do so wrong that they
left me there
i couldn't figure out what what was it
that i did that they put me in such a
bad place like this
and then
witnessing
probably the third time they tried to
come around to come and get me and i
seen the rcmp escorting them away from
the
residential area
and escorting them right down to the
dock
i told them that they came back they
were gonna be put to jail come back and
try to get me
so they never ever came back
so i've seen that so before i seen that
i was blaming my grandparents and my dad
because that's where i grew up with
i was mad at them for leaving me in such
an awful place and then wondering why
they left me there
with uh
with the help of my older relatives that
were there
made it a little bit easier at the end
because then some of the native people
started getting hired to work there at
the end of the one before it closed
but before all that there was pretty
you start to wonder today
where do they find all these mean people
you want to be like that
and then the other one is is that how
could i be
like them
as a
supposedly a christian or whatever
you didn't treat people like that
it sort of more drawn away from that
then then want to know more about it
because of those reasons
i don't believe in god i don't believe
in jesus i don't believe in it because
if there's such a thing these things
wouldn't happen just as kids
you said recently you said recently when
we talked that
there's been
news in canada about unmarked graves
found outside residential schools again
and
you said that although you'd recovered
from a lot of this to some degree and
weren't having nightmares about it
anymore that that sort of brought it
back and then you told me some pretty
terrible stories about that situation
too
when i met you jordan and a couple other
friends
i started working on things because i
trusted in it i trusted in the words
that you were you're asking me to do
i trusted that
because we were friends for a long time
and
i started working on myself
without going to a
treatment center or places like that
because i do things culturally
i remember my grandparents teachings and
cultural forms
that
it made it easier for me to live my life
without feeling like that because
stinking thinking shirt can kill a
person
inside out you won't even know that i'm
hurting
because as a
there's a child coming out of st mike
she start to learn how to cover up those
kind of pains and cover up your tears
because
you know what people are
know
because you feel ashamed of yourself and
your your dislike yourself and what
happened
you told me you told me a story about
what was done with bodies at st mike's
and the incinerator
no jordan they would they would wrap
these kids up
whether they died from
hep c or
tuberculosis
and wrap them up and they would put them
inside this big thing called the
incinerator there was a big drum really
huge drum
about six feet tall
maybe taller
and you'd fill that up with paper and
put
that wrap child in there
and
and they would make us light that fire
and the whole
time would stink the whole place of that
area would stink
it could smell
smell the body burning
charles you're you're just you must be
how old are you now you're 60 something
hey how old are you you're
62. so you had a long time to think
about this charles why in the world do
you think someone would do something
like that
do you have any you know that comes from
jordan i'm nervous you know i often
thought about that there were
where's how much anger and pain come
from how does it grow like that you know
and and then i wonder
how come
these people never got put in jail for
what they did wrong
you know if that was me doing that i'd
be in jail for a long time
or condemned from the world you can't
get a job and you'd be on tv saying oh
this guy's a rapist or a molester but
these guys have heard us not one of them
are on pictures on that stuff not one of
them being shown that these other guys
that did that through christianity
and hiding behind that skirt
so that's the things i think about
jordan how come they never got charged
for that how come they didn't do time
here we are suffering for the rest of
our lives
and then
when you talked about what happened like
these bodies that they're finding today
there nobody believes us
we were called liars that doesn't happen
people like that don't do that
you know and that's
the truth is coming out slowly but
there's more to it you know there's
going to be more to it
like how many of those
how many of these people
young ladies that were in there that had
children
from them being raped and molested in
there you know those are the things that
stuff they're resurfaced too
none of that has been brought up
and then having
never ever to see that child
you know
those are the things that are
that still haven't surfaced and why
they're not doing that why are they not
working with these women that are hurt
so badly
as a child
so you look at the reserves
we all walk around and we've got
children having children because we
don't know the difference from what
happened as
a result of this
you got out of there when you were about
13
yep
and you were angry for a long time
yeah cause i blamed the world after i
didn't know who to blame so i blamed
everybody
mostly white people
you told me about going back to see your
grandparents and recovering some of what
you had when you were a kid
because you spent a lot of time with
them when you were young
the best thing ever happened to me
jordan was having my great grandparents
live when i went home
for forever
they were there and open arms crying
it sort of scared me because i wasn't
sure what they were crying for
but it was crying and happiness that i
got to go home and stay home
so i wasn't allowed to go inside the
house
they stopped me at the doorway and i
said wait
isa
which means wait
so i stood there
and they asked me if i still know how to
speak our language and i answered them
and how i answered them with a you know
that means yes
[Music]
so my grandfather said who could i
listen to you
we're gonna go into the forest business
and you're gonna go learn who you really
are not what they thought you should be
i was really scared
i wasn't sure what was gonna happen so
as we were entering into the forest my
grandfather asked me to take my
residence to close up and leave it right
there
wherever it comes off
so as we're heading up this creek
behind
sam charlie's house sikhi's house
chief
there was a creek behind her house and
it went up towards
the back of the reserve
and there's these four big trees that
were there and a spot to sit in the
middle of these trees
he brought me there and he sat me down
and put a blanket on me
it wasn't
any blanket was his chiefs pointed
with buttons on there and
a story that told his story
of what he had pressed on his in his
treasure on his
blanket so i was really proud to wear
that
and i sat there and he gave me
a pebble
a feather
and a rattle
i'm sitting there
trying to spare well what are these for
and my grandfather says you can't leave
this area at night time you've got to
stay here no matter what
if this
or things that scare you through the
night
you use your feather and your rattle and
you pray with your brother
you ask your spirit people come watch
over you
and you use your rattle to prepare the
ground so that the spirit people can
come and look after their circle where
you're at
when you get dry son
don't leave the circle
put that pebble in your mouth
it'll help your mouth stay moist until
you're done with what you do
until you're allowed to leave that area
and perhaps your bath and have a drink
of water
so i did those things and then
after about the fourth day these trees
were talking to me
they're
it was amazing that these trees were
talking to me in our language
anyway
the the amazing thing was that when you
look at the 12-step book today that they
used for
treatment centers
they were doing it in their language but
in force
not one step but in fours
to me
and then
reading me positive affirmation about
who i am
and then nurturing that little boy
at first i couldn't understand what
little boy and that little boy was me
when i got first put in shape mics
and then
worked my way up to
being able to
handle what was going on in my life
without hurting myself and
watching watching other people suffer
the way they suffer today
knowing that
there's just a little bit of comfort
that you could find
you start that stinking thinking for all
right
charles did you tell me that when that
was happening to you out in the forest
that your great-grandfather had got
people to be behind the trees and talk
to you
they were standing there
yeah but i thought their trees were
talking to you but
when i finally got up and walked out to
go walk home
these people were behind me and they
look back and there's these chiefs
standing there behind these trees
and they're nodding their head
and that means it's okay to leave the
circle
i got enough
you can go home now
tell your grandparents what you learn
and how you feel
but when i was walking i felt like i was
on clouds
walking on cars because a lot of that
pain and pressure that i
was inside me felt like some of it
disappeared
sue them
through the positive affirmation
and then what were they telling you what
were they telling you why did it help
because they brought me to my childhood
they they made me envision me myself
standing there lit being hugged and
nurtured and looked after where i should
have been
and you're speaking in our language in
that form and
when you speak in our language jordan
it's it's
it's different it's like it's it means
more than just the sentence itself it
means more than that like when you're
when you're sitting there listening to
them tell you this
good things about yourself
you start to look at what they're saying
and what the other guy's saying because
the weather is like this
it's nice out
there the smells in the forest
who you are
what's your native name
all that gave me strength for some
reason and then they started talking
about who i should be today what
you should be learning what you should
do to make yourself
feel more comfortable with life
and to
meditate to the spirit people about
strength and be able to learn from
what it is that you're doing here why
are you here
and why i was there was to let go of
this pain that i'm carrying still today
but to be able to live through it
without hurting myself or others
charles can you tell talk more about
what happened to you in the residential
school i know these are terrible things
to talk about but people need to know
just give me a second
yep
watershed
before we did this before i knew we were
going to sit down and do this i am
i was meditating to my grandparents
about giving me strength here
up in williams lake
my family and my wife and my children
are from here
so i wanted them to learn the shoe swap
away besides my own
so i wanted to uh i like to thank the
sugarcane tribe for allowing me to be
here doing this
today
because i'm working on some things for
them about that
residential school that they had here in
some history that they taught me here
what i could put on their panel for
first of all it
if you could think of all the abuses you
can say in english or whatever
it happened in here
it really happened
and it hit it so well that people didn't
even know what's going on right next to
them
i was five five and a half years old
when i got raped by none and then i got
raped by a preacher the next day
so they
they sort of shut me down i didn't
didn't want to be around that i didn't
want to be
hurt like that i didn't want
to live like that
so they didn't really learn anything by
that what they're doing
they're being very mean
every which way you could think of
and they were tolerant bible study time
and you never seen the bible
so i really sort of don't know what's in
that bible because i don't care about it
i probably would have learned more about
it that actually showed us what it was
that we were supposed to learn
but you get brought down to the boiler
room when they would just rape you and
bless you
and make you do things to them
if you don't abide by their rules you're
gonna either get really hurt
or you're gonna be a memory
as a little kid you get really scared of
that stuff because you don't know
there's nobody there to help you there's
no parents to stop them from what
they're doing there's nobody there
not even another child could help you
because they would just get hurt with
you
i can talk about it today because it
it's not happening no more and i don't
allow that in my around my family
and i
don't wish that kind of pain on anybody
not even my worst enemy
i still
when they found out about these graves
i started having bad nightmares all over
again i started sweating really bad
my palms
and i wake up mad
because of what i was dreaming about
hey charles do you remember when we
talked about your dreams a few years ago
and you're a little kid in your dreams
and you told me you hadn't looked in the
mirror for
40 years that you wouldn't look in the
mirror
jordan
22 years i wouldn't see myself in my
face or anything because i was ashamed
of myself
you practiced looking in the mirror
to see how old you were
your dreams started to
update i phoned you that time i was a
three years ago four years ago
i was living in series
and i told you that
out of the blue i told you that you know
jordan i don't shave looking in the
mirror i don't look at myself in the
mirror and i rarely comb my hair
because i don't
don't even know what my face looks like
and then it was funny that when i seen
myself on patricia's camera oh that's me
and then i realized i was looking in the
mirror and spinning my face
back to my knees
and frankie was okay in the bathroom i
made a big thumper
and i could barely say i was okay
without letting her know i'm crying
i was crying because i missed out in 20
years of watching my face and my
hair and my body get older
i missed out on looking at myself and
because of that because of my shame of
myself of what happened to me in
residential school
i transformed my dreams to
my grandparents they're the ones my
great-grandparents they're the ones that
were teachers at that time so i thought
when my great-grandmother went to the
hospital when she had
an injury on her left leg on her top of
her foot
she's a diabetic [ __ ] had a really hard
time eating and they wanted to amputate
her foot that time
and she told
that's that
in our culture when a person loses a
limb or finger or whatever in this world
that you've done something so bad that
you got to fix it in the next world
next time
so there's no way you're taking my foot
off
i said told the doctor just to leave
call my family
so she called me in
and told me what she was doing in there
sitting there
figuring out to do that
because we i still needed to learn more
from her
she says you're moving
would you maybe not moving
well you're stitching with me i have
family members up your house right now
packing you and your family out and
you're moving on the last barrier you're
moving to camera river and i don't want
you to see me the way you're gonna swear
i'm gonna be
i want you to remember me
who i am and what i'm now not when i get
sick
and i'm begging her not to do that
because we still needed her and i still
needed more knowledge from her
she said no son i'm tired can't be here
no more
so the last fear came around and i was
like
no i don't i was on the ferry
wondering what the heck i'm doing why am
i leaving
and that was what she asked of me to do
strela
and then when i came back for the
funeral i was i was
i no no
i became like a drunk
because everybody passed away seemed
like
seemed like everybody that i got close
to or really really close to and loved
very much
they seemed to passed away on me so i
started
using my
my jinx
every time someone get close they either
get sick and die or
something happens bad
so for the longest time after my
great-grandmother died i wouldn't
take anybody as a friend for all that
close because of those dudes
and
yeah that's how i lived for always so i
just sat and
closet drink and then started drinking
on with the streets with the street
people for a few years and then
and then i sobered up because of my
great grandfather and he said that you
have to come home and learn who you are
how old were you then charles
what's that
how old were you then
17
17
you're still under age
17 18 years old
and they're not too long after that they
passed away
sure
i was having a hard time with that
because i had nowhere to go and sit and
talk to anybody no more no more elders
to learn from so i thought for a while
because i closed myself in and didn't
wanna
i didn't want to look for a new grandpa
i knew grandmother teach me i just i was
too hurt
so i i stuck to myself for a while
and then
first time i walked into a ceremony
house after a few years and
met up with bo dick and wayne alfred and
those guys and
they woke up that
carver guy inside me
and since that time i just
started looking forward on how to look
better and feel better for myself and
looking for people that are positive i
could
inhale some of that positivity you know
and learn what it feels like
let's talk about your let's talk about
your carving you said that when you met
beau dick and his he was a famous carver
and and the people that he was with that
woke something up inside of you and that
was associated with what you'd learned
from your great-grandparents when you
were a kid
they were artists they're all carvers
my great-grandfather my
great-great-grandfather and my dad they
were all carvers and were
you know professional dancers they would
call them professional dancers
and
i seen it and i wanted that i wanted to
be like my dad i wanted to be like my
grandfather so i was
when i got to hang out with the albert
carvers
it felt like i was sitting with them you
know and then
when i was sitting with these elders
learning how to carve and then started
sitting in a bowl and weighing the
people that i grew up with you know and
amongst another of the elder cars like
doug cramer and bruce alford
and and watching how they
create these beautiful things and
make it look really easy as i thought
geez i want to be that guy one day
i want to do that
so i started
carving more and more and more and then
started missing out on my job that i
used to have i used to be a logger and a
fisherman and i
i just recently sold my boat because i
like carving more than i would fishing
so um
and the thing about the carving
lifestyle is i'm still sitting here and
wearing a lake by myself carving
always by myself
but i don't feel like i'm by myself um
uh
sometimes i feel
sometimes i get scared to tell the story
that a lot of the stuff that i do comes
from my dreams and my dreams my
great-grandfather and my dad come to my
dreams and
they correct me in my car range if i get
stuck or there's something that i think
is wrong they'll remind me how to fix it
when you told me too that like i was
really struck by your carvings when i
saw that photo album and i've got a lot
of them now and
well that whole project really exploded
we could talk about that later but
you told me that very often in your
dreams you dream
in the images that you're carving that
those animals and those figures and
people those spirits as well that you
carve they're there in your dreams and
you can see them
talk to me yeah
let's say for instance i'm sitting there
and i'm working on a bear and a raven or
an eagle
and i'm all start from the bottom up
from the bottom of my pole or bottom of
my plaque and i'll work my way up to the
top
exterior that i always start with at the
bottom and work my way up
and sometimes when i'm sitting there in
my dreams these bear come to life
jump out of the plaque jump out of the
wood
and they they're there right in front of
me and
and the designs that are on them are
still on them it's just weird how that
and they're to speak in our language not
englishly speaking my language
makes me feel good that i could
practice my language without getting
whipped or strapped i guess that's why
that's
there um
yeah dreams that really helped me out
i'm going through the dreams that i get
from my great grandparents and my dad
i um
i always look forward to that then the
next night because it it's always giving
me something that i wanted to learn you
know teach from teaching me from it
and sometimes it gets scary because some
of these big animals like
come to life i don't know they're gonna
look in my dreamer
hurt me or eat me or
cause the berries are huge and the wild
woman's huge you know these things are
massive like in in my dreams they're
they're real like i mean like
the story that you're tall
it's that it's not
the carving itself it's the story that
is given to us for that and the legends
and how it's dancing used and saying
that's what brings the
strength of that bear
because it's greater than what he
actually looks like when you when he's
in your dream
he's he's big as a house he's bigger
bigger than the car right you know what
i mean
that's how big the grizzly bears are in
your drink in my dream
and the wild woman's he's tall as the
trees and
you know what i mean she's massive but
big big tall people and then you got the
book question that they're so tiny that
they're under three feet tall and it
could disappear just like that you know
so
those are those come under my dreams and
when that happens i always wake up or
i'll try to wake up right away and
sketch it before i forget it if i do
forget it and then the reason why i
don't forget my dreams is because as
soon as i wake up i talk about it
and i keep talking about it until i get
it
now how do you understand the
relationship between your art and your
dreams and your ability to stop drinking
and your willingness and wish to
straighten out your life and you haven't
had a drink for how long now
i haven't drank for 31 years
i think
i think um the reason why i quit
drinking and and drugging was because
it didn't go hand in hand with what i
was doing with art and culture it wasn't
there right it was
it didn't have those feelings that you
have when you're sitting around the art
or watching the dance go on or the
singing
it
it means
more to me
when i'm in cultural it feels
it feels like it's my church let's put
diary i think that's how i want to feel
it feels like i'm in my church when i'm
doing these things it feels like when
they're singing
and the drums are going and there's
from young kids to our elders and when
their elders walk into the ceremony how
whether they're in a wheelchair they got
a cane that just gets put down and it's
like there's no pain in that outer
because of that
singing and drumming it just
okay this is how my great grandfather
told me one time is that
you draw the energy from the guests and
then when you're dancing you give it
back
so the age is going around like this to
them through your guests and then on the
floor to the dentist and then back to
the guests back to you back to there
like that to the energy a positive
feeling good feeling
just goes around and running around and
when you leave
you leave feeling like that
like you're that dancer you're that
singer you're all of it by witnessing
that
and i think
you witnessed some of those feelings
that we've done
at your house and plus that uh ceremony
stationed back in corporate when we had
our polyps
and that was like i was in my glory when
those things go on
makes me feel really good
none of that
my childhood pain surfaces when i'm in
that zone
one of the things i found really
fascinating about the carvings was the
relationship between them and your
dreams that was extremely interesting
but also the fact that
these figures that you create are
associated in your tradition with songs
and with dances and that your families
have songs and dances that are specific
to them and carvings that are passed
down that are specific to them
it's it's very remarkable and so maybe
you could talk a little bit about that
if you would
geez that kind of art goes back
generations after generation but we're
always told when you first get put into
a dance or a mask
and your name
is you're not the owner of it you're
just a carrier that you're sharing it
for your chief your family
your treasure box
so
when you put all that in one box it's
like the treasure box you start to look
in there and see what your family
how it started where it created from
why is it belong to us why don't we use
these ones
this
in it my grandfather's daughter say
when you learn who you are sun does no
end to learning
so when you're doing cultural workers
or
being a native
and doing cultural things the way we do
to stay
be a survivor or
a hunter fisherman
or just being a father
those teachings are inside those
carvings
and when i dream about those things
there's always something like like for
instance jordan when we were talking
about
your your
holes in your house there
and
you know when you're talking about your
bear
so in my dream that bear is holding you
hugging you and letting you know that
you're the you're the chief of your
house you're the speaker of your family
you're that man
you're the teacher
and then when the eagle if your wife won
the eagle came to
the house
that was your wife's story and so we
incorporated that eagle and her and your
son and daughter into that for wrapping
around them raptor son and daughter
wrapped around the mother
you know charles charles
my friends used to call my dad wally
bear
and so that's interesting and then i
didn't realize until after you've made
those polls for me that are up on the
third floor that and i didn't know this
i should have my middle name bernd is
from my great grandfather and it it's
derived from the word for bear
yeah
wow
good one
it's amazing how things come together
and it it fits the story both sides like
mine and yours
yes it is amazing how things come
together in stories at times there's no
doubt about that
right
that that story
was already yours i just just put it in
that form
right so we love that third floor yeah
and same with your wife that was her
eagle story so that i just made it what
i how i heard it right and how i've seen
it in my dream
and and a lot of times
my dreams give me my own answers and how
i want to carve or draw something and
then i'll show my class like it's all
from clients that say have a look at
this just came from a dream and my dream
told me this
so some most of the time that oh we
should go with your dream
because it means something there's a
story that comes with that
carving or that dream and it follows
that carving
and i started like just sitting
pondering how this story is going to
come to life when i'm carving as i'm
carving i could see it coming to life
but i can't see it when i'm just looking
at this block of wood
or this blog
but once it starts forming into a totem
pole or a carbon mask
then i start to see that story that's
coming from that
that's when it comes to life is when i
start to carve it actually say i can't
tell you this sometimes the full story
time actually finished drawing or
carving what it is
because as i'm doing that
i remember stuff in my dream what
they're saying
and and
how i should say it in english
so when you came out to toronto
we started to talk about my third floor
tammy and i had kind of had this weird
dream of putting a log cabin on the top
of our
little house in toronto and you know
it's an absurd thing in some sense but
it that's really what happened because
the hole inside of that now is wood from
my great grandfather's barn and it's
full of your carvings i think there's 30
of them up there
a lot of them from the potlatch that you
hosted in on vancouver island and that
we had the privilege of attending which
was amazing thing a completely amazing
thing and when you came out here we
won't mention who who he was but i
introduced you to a good friend of mine
and he commissioned a lot of work from
you including that huge totem pole and
so maybe you could tell the story about
carving that that 50-foot totem pole
yeah 54. 54 feet yeah
54 feet with the horns on stuff
it started off with
when we first like you when you first
brought me to toronto and then we were
talking about
seamy
and his name is also charles
uh another rest
uh
he passed away on a train tracks and
anyway uh uh when you guys are telling
that story
at the at the dining table there and
then you
then you um
i was listening to the story and i guess
geez how do they know me already
i thought you guys were already talking
about me because you brought up the
they brought up charles's name a few
times and that's jamie's name
and that's my name so i thought you guys
were already talking about me so i
thought geez i didn't even have to say
nothing you guys i already know
but and then you said oh charles has a
similar story to shamey's
so um i'm i was looking at you and i was
looking at
you know uh and that just be and i said
just give me a minute i need to go
outside
and i've seen there's trees out there
right close to the house we're at there
we were having lunch that time
so i went over those trees right away
and
went out there and asked for my
my grandparents to come
give me strength to come and talk about
this over here way over in toronto
and then it
i felt that big breeze come through and
oh yeah they're here
and then i went back in and then we
started talking about that day about my
residential school and i just
i sort of gave it to you guys in a short
form that time
i think you danced then too
oh do you remember that
it wasn't long no it was really striking
you know i i was really and i was really
amazed to watch you dance because you
fell you fell into it in
in so in such a deep manner that it was
immediately entrancing
yeah it makes you feel that way that's
why i love the cultural dance the way we
dance and how we how we
you know use our masks and and what it
is that i get what i carry for my family
today
it's the hamaza right and that's a
that's a
very
important dance that our chief carries
and he puts on his son to become the
next chief
up and coming chief
and uh i was really uh
really uh thankful that uh and grateful
and honored to be uh
asked to be the muhammad in our
apartments that we had with you guys
that are in
well it was
2016 i think we're 15.
but
that was from the joseph side of the
family and i was married
my great-grandfather uh billy joseph
chieftainship
and uh my auntie and uncle asked if i
could uh
be that dancer that day because we
wanted to put it on my son and then put
it on
oh there's their son because it belonged
in that side of the family but the
family said we want it on you
i mean i said i got
thrown back by that because i thought
they would point at my son but he said
no we want it on you first so you could
put it on him
later down the road
oh
but it belongs to your son says no
we want it on you my son can't dance my
son's not ready for culture
so i stood up and
that's probably around
the first time i ever really started
crying and hugging people was around
that time and i still do that today now
oh monster
i'm not a huggy kind of guy i didn't
like it
yeah no wonder
anyways but uh that at that time i i was
uh honored to be that guy and then when
i started dancing
um with bo dicka and wayne alfred family
and
different ceremonies uh up
in our hometown like there's must have
been
invited to about
maybe
50 different classes in my
lifetime
so yeah so when i
well as you know when i get into regalia
and become myself
i transform i feel really good i got no
arthritis i got no pain i'm
really happy
my heart just jumped for joy when i'm
doing cultural work
makes you feel really good
make sure you let go of all that stuff
right you know yeah it puts you in a
different place it's partly why i like
having that art around well and good art
period because it has that
capability to
that beauty
and that depth to take you somewhere
better
yeah yeah
now this poll you you carved some
christian religious figures into that
poll
um okay uh i'll tell you a short story
on starting from the bottom of the pole
uh the bottom of the pole is the owners
of the bull and family
i'm
i'm still not allowed to use names
because of the media and stuff so but
anyway the
and then on after that is there it's
it's the cedar rope carved like you see
the rope underneath
the bottom of the woman's legs
and that cedar rope is true
for a safety or wherever that pole goes
up built because
us as uh quack quack
people will use cedarburg for
dancing and ceremony and for healing
so that's why i put that there and then
there's a woman on top of that cedar
rope and she's kneeling down and she has
her arm out
and on under each arm she's got a boy
and a girl and that's welcoming the kids
home from residential school
and then above that it's a whale and on
the whale it has faces on that whale and
those faces represent
the children that got adopted out and
never got to come home and be themselves
and why it's on the whale is because
that well goes around the world and
comes back to where it belongs
i thought that was fitting that the
children did that went somewhere and
then came back and didn't feel like they
belonged
so i put that on the whale and then
after the well i made a raven and
they're even you know
this was a trickster
you know they're very smart ravens
they like to play too
so i thought what would be spitting on
that raven was i put a preacher and a
nun on the wings and then i put a cross
down the middle of that raven's chest
the reason why i used the raven was
because of how these christianity people
tricked our people into taking our
elders first
and it didn't work
so they put the elders back and took the
children away
and put us in these residential schools
but they first they tried to do that
with elders and then they put us back
put them back because they didn't they
were kids are still learning
so they put the elders back and took the
kids away
and that's when they found it as more
effective
so
you know it's the thing about
when your life changes over and over
like when i first met you guys
i want to live like that i want to feel
like that
so i
i look for people like that now i look
for positive people that feel good about
themselves
and
um
not
i'm not trying to brag or anything but
it it
it's good to feel like that it it it's
it makes me feel good that i when i'm
like that i can carve happy mess i feel
good i'm
i'm not
frustrated inside or hurt inside where
my mask is gonna feel like that right or
am i crying
so when i do tone pulls
i wanna feel like that and when i'm not
feeling good about things i won't go to
that hole that next day or something if
i'm feeling down oh there's something
sad or a death going on
i won't go around my art until i feel
better
and
i don't know why i do that it's just
something out of respect for the spirit
people are the respect for the teachers
that taught me the art
uh i guess that's
learning
learning how to deal with respect in in
that way
learning what to respect too
yeah look there's
with alcoholism there's a scientific
literature on alcohol abuse and one of
the most effective treatments for
alcohol abuse is spiritual
transformation it's the only
it's the only
treatment so to speak for alcoholism
that's really been validated
and so that's that's really quite
something and you know you said that you
found something that was more important
fundamentally i mean there's more to it
than that but
that's to be taken seriously you know i
quit drinking
when i was about 28
and the reason i quit was because i was
writing well there was a couple of
reasons i was having kids and i wasn't
going to drink when i had little kids i
that just wasn't a good idea
and
you know the only time i was doing
things that i would be ashamed of the
next day or
a week later or something it was always
if i was drinking and so i thought well
maybe i don't want to do things i'm
ashamed of anymore
but also
because i was writing and i was writing
about mythology and stories and all of
that it was very hard work and very
emotionally demanding but i couldn't do
it well if i was hungover
and so i thought well which do i want to
be do i want to write this book or do i
want to be hungover
and so i stopped and i stopped for
30 years i guess i i drank a little bit
again when i was in my early 50s but i
quit again after that because i found
that
even though it's about 25 years had gone
by if i drank again i usually drank too
much and then i d you know was likely to
do something stupid and i thought well
no
it's just not worth it at all it's not
worth it
yeah i'm laughing with you
yeah yeah i know i understand
and so how many people worked with you
on that on those those big poles that
you produced i mean you produced some
eight footers for me eight and ten feet
i guess the welcome figure must be nine
feet about
when i worked on your stuff journalists
just the family me ocean james and
frankie
and when i worked on that big 54-foot
project there was
oceana james
frankie myself
my brother leonard my brother gordon my
late nephew johnny and my nephew mike
and
orbit
leonard junior
and i said i said if it was uh like like
i've always done there's always family
effort right i make sure i keep my
family involved and and so they
they keep in touch with culture
and then when we had that ceremony
a lot of my family members didn't make
it but when the ones that did make it
they were never you know introduced to
the culture because they lived in
vancouver all their lives are
urbanized
so when they got to come home there was
a big teaching to them too right because
they were you've never ever been
involved in it
so it's good to see that uh
it works
was it good for them to do the carving
oh jesus into seeing how they felt when
it got stood up
they were so proud of being part of that
you know what i mean and
i was proud to see that
how happy they look when they've seen
the creation that we did together as a
family
stood up somewhere where we're never
going to probably go again you know
who knows
yeah that was it and so what do you
think about it being in montreal and the
busiest street there pretty much
sherbrooke's a major street i mean
it's one of the main streets of montreal
it's beautiful street and it's in front
of the museum of fine art which is
really something because that's
definitely one of the finest museums in
canada
it doesn't look like it's going anywhere
soon no
uh well i mentioned to them that you
know
one day you guys should return this pool
and get your own
[Laughter]
but uh um and i tried to approach them
with another idea as that as i would
like to take a log there
to the mohawk people or raw log and then
work with the mohawk artist and see what
we can come up with
and
that's that's one of the ideas i had
just to
um
are do you have more of a car
certain reconciliation with another
tribe it's i don't know if i want to
call it that i think it's just to
to rekindle what our elders did before
us you know and get go back to
uh being related in in
all the nations across uh
canada i guess
right so when you've approached the
museum with that idea what happened um
because that's a great idea do you have
mohawk carvers that are interested
i i knew of a couple that were and then
we were gonna first get that idea on the
table then i was gonna bring it to the
mohawk chiefs that i that i then invited
to the poll region and then see what
would become of it
yeah so
i haven't heard nothing back from that
yet but
one good thing that came out of that
since that time though as
they had this thing that they're talking
about the totem pole inside the museum
and then they had
people make footprints
and what they thought about the story of
the pool and then they leave their
footprint behind
i think that's one of the things that
they did there and then
on the 30th of last month they weren't
uh national with the story of the poll
i haven't got any feedback on my site
and stuff about it yet but soon i guess
so can i ask you a political question or
two
yeah why not
well you know canada is hypothetically
engaging in this soul-searching process
this reconciliation process and
i'm kind of curious about
i mean there's parts of it that i'm
really not very
i don't feel good about like for example
now before most
ceremonies
before my most public events in eastern
canada
there is
a statement about the land that
this
the people this land once belonged to it
i don't like that because it it seems
hypocritical to me and and and not real
and i think it's showy and false and
well that might just be me but
i'm pretty curious about you're looking
at this from
well from a completely different
perspective than me and
like what do you think about this
reconciliation effort and has it been
helpful to you and to people you know
and
is it real and
okay jordan i need to
ask you something
this has been on my mind for a while and
i wanted to ask you that quite a while
ago but
what does
that mean reconciliation what notice
that in my mind that that means two
parties that are
are
two parties that are saying they did
something wrong
and and trying to fix it
that's that's what my thoughts what
reconciliation means but that's why i
don't agree with it
because we're not the ones in the fall
here they are
i'm going to tell you a story charles
okay
i want to tell you a story
this is a story that a friend of mine
who committed suicide wrote
uh he lived up in
in high pr high prairie high level i
think it was high level in alberta and
there were a lot of native kids there
and
he was probably around 10 or so and he
used to get beat up fairly regularly and
was often by the native kids and he
wouldn't fight back
and the reason he wouldn't fight back
was because he felt guilty
and that guilt you know that guilt about
i don't know it's the horrible hand of
history i suppose charles that guilt
like that eventually ate him up and
killed him now he had other problems but
okay where did his guilt come from
well he felt that he was an interloper
and he was an occupier and he didn't
have the right to fight back and
so he wouldn't fight back
and you know then he
he uh decided when he was a teenager
that anything he did that was sort of
masculine and achievement-oriented and
ambitious was wrong because it was
associated with all this historical
cruelty
and so he just stopped himself from
doing anything and
it killed him
it's not that uncommon you know and i've
been thinking about this a lot you you
look into the history of mankind and
it's pretty damn bleak you know
there's a lot of horror in the past a
lot of bloodshed a lot of warfare a lot
of cruelty a lot of malevolence
and we all have to contend with that
and like for me that you asked about
reconciliation for me it's getting to
know you you know i had some native
friends when i grew up it was it was
hard there was a big gap yeah
you know i'll tell you a story i'll
remember this man so i i had this friend
off and on friend he was a native guy
his name was dennis helly i think dennis
is still alive and
we kind of had a friendship in grade six
and he was a big rough kid and i was a
bit afraid of him but he was a good guy
good looking kid and he was smart
but
and we were trying to have a friendship
and i'd invited him to go to the movie
with me that night and then we were
sitting in class and my dad was teaching
the class and
dennis was chewing gum
and my dad said dennis stop chewing that
gum you sound like a cow and i said
dennis the cow ha ha
and then he looked at me
and he like
and he meant you're you're dead after
school
and so i was terrified the whole damn
day and after school i zipped out by
where where the bikes were
and dennis came after me and i was sort
of running around the bikes and
trying to stay away from him and i sort
of hid behind this i don't know what it
was there was some structure there and
he was on the other side of it and i
said
dennis you know we could stop fighting
i'd still like to go to the movie with
you tonight
and he broke into tears and ran home
yeah
so reconciliation that's a hard thing eh
yeah and maybe that's kind of what you
and i are doing i think so
but what i wanted to do it's not easy
you know because
there's a lot of bad blood and there's a
lot of horror and
and none of us really know how to do it
you know we come from very different
places and we don't know how to make
that work
it's not a simple thing
or why it happened you know why why are
we so separated
and then the greatest thing is now we're
together
not just well that's something isn't it
and the totem pole is in montreal and
that's something too we're not just
friends we're family
yeah
that's what i mean about the greatest
thing for me is how we reconnect is
right and how you and i met and why
you know i think a lot of this sort of
thing has to be done at the individual
level you know
and then what i love about it is that we
stay we're still connected we're still
growing
yeah we're doing our best man
yeah and i love that it makes me feel
good that i'm part of that
yeah me too
it's really been something charles this
all these things that we've been through
it was it was hard you know i've been
sick for about three years now and i
haven't talked to you much
didn't have the stamina for it
you know i was pretty
isolated myself from pretty much
everybody except my immediate family
but we've been on some great adventures
you and me that potlatch was really
something that ceremony you know when
you you and your guys came and you and
your wife too your whole family came to
my house to do the ceremony to open the
third floor
that was the same day
so that was when i was inducted into
your family you know people have made
fun of that and said that i was lying
and well it's not a lie
and
and that was the same day that i was
being accused of being a bigot and a
racist at the university it was the same
goddamn day the same day the debate the
there was a big debate there when
everything blew up around me so i went
from this debate where you know i was
basically being accused of being a
racist and a bigot to this ceremony in
my house where i was inducted into your
family it was a pretty damn weird day i
can tell you that
okay when we've got to change that word
abducted
when we were
when we
chose our family had a meeting and we
had a meeting with all of my joseph
family and some hereditary chiefs about
adopting you and your family into our
family in the ceremony house
and then the chiefs had asked me
what was their reason for doing that
and i explained to them what
how we've met and how long i've been
friends with you and your wife and kids
and then
the importance of hanging on to that
friendship and the importance of
what i was not just
sharing with you but also learning from
you
and and your family
and what what it was that i i really was
yawning for was that
living in a happy positive way that you
guys lived in and i wanted some of that
hungry part so
i wanted to inhale all i could from you
guys
and learn from it
and it makes me feel really good to be
part of that because who would have
thought that
i would understand those feelings but i
do
and it's an awesome feeling to have is
been able to have positiveness in your
feelings even if it's just for a moment
yeah
yeah i know
charles i'm going to say goodbye for
today
hey jordan it's been awesome talking and
it's good to see you bro and uh you keep
up the good work
hey i'm looking forward to seeing what
you produce in your dreams for my new
house
[Music]
you